[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans auditions
publiques sur Public Sénat et SCP et ça
y est le paysage politique se précise en
attendant le discours de politique
génération sur LCP mercredi l'équipe
gouvernementale a été annoncé ce matin
plus d'une quarantaine de ministres ou
secrétaire d'État plusieurs nouveaux de
la société civile quelques revenants et
plusieurs partants est-ce que ce
gouvernement vous inspire je vous pose
la question dans quelques minutes
bonjour Valérie rabot bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes à votre
troisième mandat sauf erreur vous avez
été réélu dans le Tarn-et-Garonne
félicitations avec l'étiquette ou sous
l'étiquette Nupe cette fois vous êtes
chef du groupe PS socialiste socialiste
mais votre mais vous aviez été investi
par la nuque oui mais voilà
et libre et c'est une étiquette
socialiste loyal eBay tiens on
connaissait déjà ingénieur de formation
[Musique]
vous êtes ingénieur de formation vous
êtes ce qu'on appelle une budgétaire
vous connaissez très bien ces questions
là vous auriez pu être pardon vous
auriez pu être dans ce gouvernement en
tout cas ça vous a été proposé après la
présidentielle je crois vous avez dit
non est-ce que cette fois Emmanuel
Macron ou son entourage son revenu à la
charge non ils avaient compris le
message non mais je crois que un
gouvernement ce n'est pas assez certes
une équipe mais le casting passe après
la politique et la ligne et la boussole
qu'on souhaite donner au pays et je
pense que pour faire partie d'un
gouvernement il faut partager cette
boussole peut-être pas à 100% mais à 95
et je j'étais trop éloignée je suis trop
éloignée de ce que le président de la
République souhaite mettre en oeuvre de
ce que j'en ai compris à ce stade
puisque nous avons une campagne
présidentielle qui a été quand même peu
assez timide sur les propositions sur le
cap qu'on souhaite donner au pays parce
qu'en dehors de la retraite à 65 ans je
ne sais pas et bien
en temps mettre en oeuvre on en parlera
tout à l'heure effectivement en tout cas
on en saura plus vous espérez j'imagine
mercredi avec la feuille de route
d'Elizabeth borne l'équation est
complexe des comptes publics
catastrophiques des attentes fortes très
fortes en matière de pouvoir d'achat
justement est-ce que vous approuvez les
mesures déjà connues les vôtres et vous
quels sont les vôtres côté recettes
taxer les super profits c'est forcément
très populaire est-ce que c'est
souhaitable Brigitte Boucher est
intranet vous poseront des questions
elle vous interrogeront aussi sur le
vote de confiance ou plutôt le nom de
confiance puisque ça a été conformé il
n'y en aura pas Yves straya rappellera
que vous êtes au Parti socialiste qui
semble avaler aujourd'hui par léfi et à
19h10 ce sera le temps de la disputation
du débat avec le député MoDem Richard
Ramos on revient d'abord quelques
instants sur ce gouvernement Valérie
rabot Emmanuel Macron est intervenu en
début de conseil des ministres qui a qui
a succédé de quelques heures
de ce gouvernement et il a dit ceci
entre autres on l'écoute
la première ministre m'a rendu compte
vendredi du résultat des consultations
conduites la semaine dernière
il convient de prendre acte de l'absence
de volonté d'une partie du gouvernement
de participer à un accord de
gouvernement
donc si on entend le Président il vous a
proposé vous avez dit non vous avez fait
capoter le projet de quoi de coalition
c'est ça le président de la République
évoque un accord de gouvernement pour
qui Accor il faut qu'il y ait
négociation qu'on mette sur la table
est-ce que oui ou non le président de la
République est prêt à se remettre en
oeuvre le SMIC à 1500 euros nets dans
notre pays
n'avons pas eu de réponse est-ce qu'il
est prêt à aller sur l'idée qu'on est
une vraie planification écologique nous
n'avons pas une réponse est-ce que sur
la réforme des retraites il est prêt à
dire ben non 65 ans ça conduit à amener
15 milliards d'euros dans les caisses de
l'État et donc à faire payer les
personnes qui ont l'espérance de Villa
plus courte et celles qui ont les
salaires les moins élevés et donc mais
là dessus nous nous avons été pour le
coup nous avons vraiment été très clair
et par contre nous n'avons pas eu la
réponse aussi claire de la part de
président de la République ou en tout
cas la première ministre donc on peut
donc vous vous prenez comme il a dit
vous prenez acte du fait qu'il vous a
pas donné suffisamment de précision pour
un accord de gouvernement quand on veut
un accord il faut être plusieurs assigné
autour de la table et par définition il
faut s'être mis d'accord politique ça
peut pas être un débauchage alors
gouvernement on va venir sur toutes les
questions de fond elles sont très
importantes mais d'abord est-ce qu'il y
a des bonnes surprises dans ce
gouvernement non mais il y a des
personnalités qui sont
plusieurs que je connais et qui sont qui
ont des parcours extrêmement
intéressants mais un gouvernement c'est
pas la Star Academy un gouvernement
c'est de définir une politique pour la
France pour le cap depuis le 24 avril on
a un peu tous en attente de savoir ce
qui va se passer pour notre pays on peut
pas être comme ça avoir une absence de
réponse sur des sujets qui sont
extrêmement importants vous avez cité
tout à l'heure en introduction les
finances publiques qui sont dans un état
catastrophique c'est vrai afin mais on
est déjà à manière de rôle déficit mais
nous avions demandé dès avril 2020 une
conférence de financement parce qu'on
sait très bien qu'une crise ça doit se
financer et qu'il faut se mettre
d'accord on va revenir on va revenir sur
ces sujets mais je reste un peu pardon
quand même sur le casting un mot de
Olivier Klein merps de Clichy-sous-Bois
par exemple c'est un spécialiste de la
rénovation de urbaine elle a fait l'étau
logement vous dites bon s'il a les
moyens de sa politique c'est un bon
choix ben s'il a les moyens de sa
politique il est au bon endroit c'est
évident que sur le logement il a fait
ses preuves sur le logement il a
beaucoup d'idées mais encore une fois
quel est quel sera son cap je n'en sais
rien un mot quand même aussi d'un des
événements de ce gouvernement si vous
parliez d'autres personnes Laurence Boon
qui intervient pas François Hollande et
conseils que vous la connaissez qui
travaille à l'OCDE qui travaille à
l'OCDE qui a donc une des relations
internationales extrêmement importantes
qui connaît les pays donc effectivement
c'est c'est ce sont des personnalités
qui intr ont de la valeur mais la
question qui se pose c'est qu'est-ce qui
se passe sur la ligne gouvernementale et
pour l'instant ces grands mystère je
vous poserai la question tout à l'heure
sur Damien bad vous me direz si c'est le
bon choix et quel doit être d'ailleurs
la règle dans ces situations toujours
délicates avec
l'envie de soutenir le principe
démocratique de la présomption
d'innocence mais face à des accusations
ça sera intéressant de voir quelles
règles vous voudriez voir appliquer mais
d'abord on va rejoindre Vincent roux en
direct du Figaro live bonsoir Vincent
bonsoir Elisabeth bonsoir Valérie rabot
alors quel est votre question à Valérie
rabot
c'est peut-être une autre affaire
puisqu'on parle à Damien Abad de votre
point de vue Valérie rabot est-ce que
Eric Coquerel est ce soir fragilisé à
son poste de président de la commission
des finances avec les accusations d'une
anciene militante d'une ancienne
militante qui vient de porter plainte
pour harcèlement sexuel
vraiment je pense que le principe de
présomption d'innocence est très
important puisqu'il y a eu un dépôt de
plainte je souhaite que la justice
puisse traiter rapidement cette affaire
qui évite que la commission des finances
soit moi je vais vous le dire j'étais
sidérée que la journée d'hier ce soit
concentrée que sur cette question là qui
a une pleine page entière dans le
Journal du dimanche alors même que
personne ne parle des déficits de l'État
personne ne parle le fait que on a des
matières premières pour lesquelles on
n'arrive pas à s'approvisionner etc etc
qui remettent en cause la sécurité de
notre pays la sécurité de l'Europe donc
j'aimerais bien qu'on parle des vrais
sujets puisqu'il y a eu un dépôt de
plainte et bien j'espère que la justice
va pouvoir la traiter rapidement et puis
ce qu'on en parle beaucoup on va purger
aussi très vite Vincent roux est-ce que
justement vous regrettez de ne pas avoir
été proposé par la nuque pour présider
cette commission des finances parce que
dans ce cas-là il y aurait pas eu ce
problème alors si je le regrette oui si
je me suis fait une raison oui et je ne
siège pas la commission des finances je
mange visage pas d'ici j'ai ou en tout
cas sur la première année de cette
législature après on verra ce qui se
passera après mais en tout cas je ne n'y
reviendrai pas je siège à la commission
de défense et je suis ravie de si j'ai
dans cette commission ravi petite
déception vous l'avez digéré vous savez
moi je suis
réserviste dans la réserve citoyenne de
l'armée de terre du 17e régiment de
régie ni parachutiste de Montauban donc
j'ai vraiment une grande affection pour
militaire pour l'engagement qu'ils ont
pour la France donc je suis ravie de
sier à la Commission de la Défense je ne
reviendrai pas à la commission des
finances mais ça ne m'empêchera pas de
travailler sur un budget alternatif de
répondre d'interpeller aussi le
gouvernement sur les questions lors du
domicile on va parler exactement
Brigitte boucher merci beaucoup Vincent
à tout à l'heure Brigitte boucher tome 3
nuits bonsoir
précises bonsoir Valérie rabot alors
mercredi Elisabeth borne va faire son
discours de politique générale à
l'Assemblée nationale elle ne demandera
pas la confiance ça a bien été confirmé
tout à l'heure par Olivier Véran nouveau
porte-parole du gouvernement est-ce que
vous le regrettez mais oui mais elle
fait une erreur magistrale elle est la
25 premières ministre depuis 1958 sous
la Cinquième 25e 25e première ministre
bon sur ces 25 premiers ministres il y
en a que deux qui n'ont jamais
sollicité la confiance alors pas
forcément sur les discours de politique
générale de manière générale qui sont
couvent
une espérance de Première ministre sans
doute assez courte si on s'appuie sur
ces deux statistiques lui produisait pas
le deuxième sujet le deuxième sujet elle
est la deuxième femme à exercer cette
fonction de Première ministre et bien
elle devrait être deux femmes ont pris
le même choix mais justement c'était une
erreur elle devrait prendre un maximum
d'indépendance même si bien sûr la
Cinquième République prévoit qu'elle est
nommée par le Président de la République
mais elle devrait s'affirmer et
s'affirmer ça passe par avoir la
confiance du Paris ça veut dire que vous
seriez prête éventuellement à voter
cette confiance
mais ça passe par une mais pourquoi elle
n'aurait pas le confiance ou s'en
servait à rien vous savez
la maman était relative mais la majorité
est relative elles vont tenir compte
c'est à dire que elle peut aussi mettre
dans son programme ou dans ce qu'elle
veut mettre en œuvre des propositions
qui ne viennent pas la majorité relative
je reviendrai sur l'histoire du SMIC à
1500 euros la programmation écologique
toutes ces questions-là peuvent être
mises sur la table donc elles viennent
erreur d'obligation
première ministre elle fait une erreur
en tant que femme ah bon elle fait une
erreur en tant que femme
[Musique]
on est toujours on a toujours besoin de
faire ses preuves et faire ses preuves
ça passe par le vote moi j'ai été la
première femme rapporteur du budget j'ai
été élu j'étais la première femme
présidente d'un groupe depuis que
l'Assemblée nationale existe j'ai été
élu l'élection s'est présentée
comme les 577 députés l'Assemblée
nationale et ils sont pas tous première
ministre que je sache et donc ça ça
permet de crédibiliser sa fonction ça
permet d'asseoir sa fonction et
la mort
elle a besoin de plus de légitimité
parce que c'est une femme
elle n'a pas besoin de plus parce que
c'est une femme mais elle a besoin à
minima ça fait 30 ans 30 ans qu'un
premier ministre n'a pas demandé la
confiance de l'Assemblée nationale la
dernière fois qu'un premier ministre ne
l'a pas fait c'est en 1992 ça fait ça
fait 30 ans et bien la démocratie évolue
l'Assemblée nationale évolue et elle
sera la première depuis 30 ans à ne pas
demander cette confiance c'est la
première fois de la Cinquième République
et une majorité relative de ce niveau là
vous pouvez aussi mettre ça en regard ne
met pas d'obligation en plus il n'y a
aucune obligation je vous me demandais
mon avis je vous le donne je pense que
quand on est une femme on a besoin de
véritablement asseoir son pouvoir elle
est chef de la majorité chef du
gouvernement elle doit être très clair
elle doit demander d'aller faire et je
ne suis réaction à ce qu'a dit votre
collègue de la nuque Mathilde panot elle
a déclaré dans un tweet cette adresse à
Elisabeth borne on ne maltraite pas la
démocratie impunément nous vous ferons
donc venir de force devant le Parlement
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ces propos
est-ce que vous reprendriez c'est moi
votre compte non pourquoi non parce que
la première ministre vous l'avez rappelé
elle a le choix de
susciter enfin de demander ou pas à la
confiance moi je pense qu'elle fait une
erreur une double erreur à la fois
historique quand on regarde ce qui s'est
passé depuis 30 ans vis-à-vis aussi du
fait qu'elle soit la deuxième femme
première ministre mais vous ne diriez
pas ça mais je dirais pas les choses
comme ça parce que je pense que les
institutions faire venir de force non
mais personne ne fait venir de force
personne on est dans une démocratie on
respecte les institutions en tout cas
moi je suis la première à les respecter
de force ça veut dire quoi c'est-à-dire
on va vous chercher à Matignon et on va
vous amener de force devant l'hémicycle
non c'est pas comme ça que les choses se
passent donc non je ne suis pas d'accord
avec cette formulation de violence dans
cette façon de s'opposer alors pas je
cible pas Mathilde pano mais dans le
débat en général et ce qui est monté de
violence dans les rapports de force
entre oui oui mais parce que les 577
députés et puis tous celles et ceux qui
ont été candidats lors de sélection
législatives ont ressenti cette violence
il y a une fracturation qui existe dans
le pays et cette fracturation elle peut
parfois débouché sur la violence moi je
suis très critique de cela mais j'étais
bien j'ai d'observer au cours de ces
mois de campagne que la fracturation qui
existe dans la société peut parfois
déboucher sur de la violence et c'est
très inquiétant ce que vous voulez sans
doute je pense que quand on est député
il faut surtout pas la susciter d'accord
voilà
c'est ses propos c'est parce qu'elle a
confirmé après c'est le dépôt d'une
motion de censure pour éventuellement
faire tomber le gouvernement et
Elisabeth borne est-ce que le PS va
s'associer à cette motion de censure qui
sera déposée mercredi il y aura une
discussion en réunion de groupe il faut
toujours faire attention avec l'émotion
de censure parce que quand elles sont
pas votées
des facto elle donne la légitimité au
gouvernement place voilà c'est ce qui
peut se passer éventuellement parce que
le RN a dit qu'il ne s'associerait pas à
une motion de censure de la France
insoumise donc elle sera là des chances
donc ça se fait mathématique donc il
faudrait pas dire
c'est que
une motion de censure nous en débattrons
demain leur de la réunion du groupe
socialiste à parenté effectivement si
elle est pas votée ça renforce confort
du coup vous personnellement vous n'êtes
pas favorable à cette
motions
je vais reprendre ce que j'ai dit en
début de cette émission je suis loyale
et libre c'est à dire que je suis libre
des propos je peux tenir dans ma réunion
dans la réunion de groupe de mon groupe
mais je suis aussi loyale parce que je
pense que c'est important qui on puisse
respecter lorsqu'on appartient à une un
groupe politique qu'on puisse aussi
respecter des décisions prises à la
majorité ça veut dire ça veut dire que
livre la beauté libre je dirais demain
matin que je n'y suis pas favorable lors
de ma réunion de groupe si mon groupe
décide de s'y associer je serais loyal
donc vous la voterez avec le groupe S si
toutefois il décidait
demain d'accord mais si vous vous
désolidarisez
demain matin si vous vous désol
solidariser de la nuque ce qui est
possible ça veut dire que c'est la fin
de l'Alliance quelque part mais ça veut
dire quoi se désolidariser on est quatre
groupes parlementaires on a une
autonomie sur les propositions que nous
voulons formuler sinon ça veut dire
qu'on serait pas un groupe parlementaire
c'est un fait majeur quand même une
émotion c'est important quelque chose de
très d'accord si on veut si on veut qui
est une comment dire un accord de 4
groupes il semble mieux d'en discuter
avant à 4 plutôt que d'aller
médias
est-ce qu'il y a finalement deux types
d'oppositions d'un côté une forme
d'obstruction de la part de la France
insoumise et puis de l'autre côté une
opposition qui serait peut-être un peu
plus constructive puisque vous êtes
prêtes à éventuellement trouver des
actions
j'ai jamais été favorable mais j'observe
quand même que la majorité va avoir de
gros efforts à fournir si on regarde ce
qui s'est passé sous le quinquennat
précédent ou même
tous les groupes pensées différemment
d'elles elle a cherché à passer en force
et ça dans le contexte actuel c'est pas
bon du tout du soleil il y a plus de
majorité absolue donc la nécessité de
négocier ça va nécessiter une
négociation le gouvernement d'Elisabeth
borne soit prêt à faire des concessions
pour trouver des compromis des premiers
test sera le projet de l'aide financière
et ce sera là pour le coup ce sera une
position de vérité de la part du
gouvernement c'est plus ça le premier
test que le projet de loi sur le pouvoir
d'achat qui arrive aussi oui bah c'est
c'est un projet de loi de rectif donc on
a compris que les deux textes différents
qui allaient de pairs enfin qui allait
ensemble alors moi je sais pas si ce
sera deux textes différents j'avais
compris que c'était un texte de loi de
finances un pochette pouvoir d'achat oui
une aura une partie à la commission des
affaires sociales sans doute mais en
tout cas l'équilibre budgétaire il est
dans la loi de finance rectificative
est-ce que le gouvernement
de vouloir faire un 49-3 là dès le début
mais je n'en sais rien moi je suis pas
dans les petits papiers du gouvernement
ni non c'est secret j'observe juste vous
me posez la question que ce sera un test
de vérité de la capacité du gouvernement
à négocier ou pas mais on va passer
justement des cas concrets bon déjà il y
a un peu l'esprit de ce projet de loi on
connaît un certain nombre de mesures le
vendeur prime transport remise carburant
revalorisation du point d'indice etc
est-ce que vous vous pouvez voter
vraiment contre ces mesures qui sont
très attendues on sait par les Français
qui vont dans le sens d'augmenter leur
pouvoir d'achat mais qui sont très
attendus vous prenez les 17 millions de
Français qui chaque jour prennent la
voiture pour aller travailler parce
qu'ils sont pas transports en commun il
y a deux ans il y a encore un an nous
avions proposé qui est un chèque qui
soit l'équivalent d'un plein alors
qu'ils sont entre 70 80 euros par mois
comme vous qui vivez en Île-de-France et
bien vous avez votre passe Navigo et
votre employeur vous en paye la moitié
donc les transports vous coûtent entre
35 et 40 euros par mois chez moi en
terme et Garonne c'est plutôt entre
années 50 et 300 euros par mois donc
vous comprenez bien qu'il y a une grande
injustice ça là-dessus nous avons
formulé des propositions ce qui est
proposé à ce stade par le gouvernement
c'est insuffisant et on est loin ça vous
pouvez vous pourriez ne pas le voter
même si vous savez que je suis
on a voté la prime inflation ça vous
aura pas échappé même si je pense
qu'elle était mal ciblée qu'elle était
qu'elle enfin elle a été un hyper mal
ciblé parce que je rappelle que une mère
seule qui gagne 2010 euros avec trois
enfants il n'y avait pas le droit mais
on n'allait pas priver plusieurs
millions de Français
sur toutes les prestations sociales moi
j'invite le gouvernement vous pouvez pas
refuser ça au français mais je tombais
laissez-moi finir j'invite le
gouvernement à être sérieux c'est à dire
à arrêter de faire des rustines il y a
tout mettre sur la table qui nous disent
exactement ce qu'il va faire pour les 17
millions de Français qui chaque jour
prennent leur voiture pour aller
travailler et pas seulement pour 4 ou 5
qui nous le disent vraiment et que là on
puisse avoir une une discussion
idem sur le financement j'observe que
c'est la première fois
qu'un gouvernement n'a pas transmis en
avril sa copie budgétaire c'est la
première fois même quand François
Hollande a fini son mandat en 2017 il a
transmis une copie budgétaire là on a
l'impression que tout se passe comme
s'il fallait cacher des choses moi j'ai
regardé quoi mais je soupçonne rien du
tout
pour l'instant le gouvernement est
incapable de rendre une copie financée
c'est à dire de nous dire comment il
finance ces mesures et les 500
et en parallèle de ça il est incapable
de nous dire aussi les 7 milliards de
TVA qu'il a en plus à fin mai dans les
caisses de l'État qu'est-ce comment il
compte comment il compte les distribués
on va envoyer
qui ont des précises véritables
difficultés de pouvoir d'achat de deux
propositions vraiment à gauche de
propositions de la nuque il y a le SMIC
à 1500 euros oui puis il y a le blocage
des prix par exemple si le gouvernement
ne retient pas ses propositions à ce que
vous rejetez forcément l'ensemble parce
que ce sont vos lignes rouge voilà des
choses non négociables pour vous alors
sur le SMIC à 1500 euros nets c'est
quand même vraiment indispensable on va
arriver à une inflation sans doute à 8%,
une inflation à 8% pour que vous gardiez
le même pouvoir d'achat ça fait un 13e
mois
si le gouvernement vous comprenez bien
que les 100 euros par rapport à un 13e
mois on est loin du compte donc si le
gouvernement ne répond pas là-dessus
c'est le barrage vous dites on peut pas
voter si vous ne répondez pas là dessus
non en général nous on n'a jamais donné
de chèques en blanc et ça vous aura pas
échappé que le débat on le fait dans
l'hémicycle et qu'on voit qu'elles sont
aussi les avancées qu'on peut obtenir du
gouvernement donc si mon reposer cette
question dans deux semaines je vous
répondrai mais là la séance n'a pas
commencé et ceux qui sont au SMIC
aujourd'hui qui vont de fait perdre de
pouvoir d'achat si vous augmentez que le
SMIC les bas salaires finalement non
mais on a aussi une conférence salariale
sur le pour que les salaires au dessus
du SMIC puisse être aussi revalorisée
mais ça suppose
avec
moi c'est déjà le cas il y a pas eu
depuis très longtemps de grandes
négociations
salariale alors oui ça a été le cas
propose des choses puisque beaucoup
d'entreprises ont du mal à recruter donc
c'est notamment dans la restauration
donc ça avec 0 garanti pour le coup
aujourd'hui ils ont 0 garantie mais
l'objectif c'est bien de mettre des
garanties aussi dans le débat dans le
débat budgétaire pour pas que l'été et
les PME qui font face à la hausse du cou
des matières premières qui font face à
des pénuries aussi pour de fin des
difficultés de recrutement ne soient pas
étranglées qui font face à du
remboursement de pg-e qui aurait pu être
mieux négocié pour pas que des taux
d'intérêt qui soit appliqués dessus donc
tout ça ce sont des questions qui se
posent mais la question la question
pardon de Tom c'était les 1500 euros
nets oui le SMIC à 1500 est-ce que ça
pour vous c'est une condition
sinequanone mais pour voter le paquet ça
c'est une condition non mais c'est une
condition que nous avons re mentionné à
la première ministre en lui disant vous
rendez bien compte que face à au choc
d'inflation que nous avons c'est
indispensable alors je vois bien qu'il
tourne autour du pot pour l'instant ils
l'ont peut-être pas mis peut-être que ça
ça aboutira mais pour nous c'est
vraiment augmenter le SMIC
comment on soutient aussi les TPE et PME
qu'est-ce qu'on leur comment les
accompagnement
comment on les accompagne sur cette
augmentation qui est indispensable donc
tout ça je veux que ce soit mis sur la
table pour l'instant il y a pas une
discussion ouverte encore toujours sur
l'inflation est-ce que comme
Michel-Edouard Leclerc vous pensez que
toutes les hausses de prix dans les
supermarchés ne sont pas justifiées on
voit la France insoumise aujourd'hui le
rassemblement national
oui alors je sais pas s'il faut une
commission d'enquête moi je vous avoue
pour pourtant bien regarder le sujet je
ne comprends pas
de telles hausse d'inflation d'accord
donc il y a des gens qui profitent il y
a des peut-être des marques des comprend
pas de la grande distribution et je
souhaite que j'aimerais peut-être les
éviter que l'INSEE puisse nous donner
des éclairages peut-être plus précis sur
certaines causes de hausse de prix qui
sont parfois très importantes on a eu
beaucoup de débats par exemple sur
l'huile de tournesol et autres alors que
c'est la production de 2021 qui en jeu
donc moi je souhaite y voir plus clair
parce que il est vrai qu'à ce stade du
coup sous quelle forme qu'est-ce que
vous avez demandé une mission de
l'Inspection des finances justement sur
les hausses de prix sur l'inflation ça
irait ça mais oui oui s'il y a des
conclusions qui sont qui sont
sais pas comment dire solide en mode
sujet verbe complément et qu'on y
comprennent bien quelque chose parce que
il y a sur l'énergie
sur l'énergie on voit à peu près qu'il
peut y avoir un problème avec la guerre
en Ukraine sur la provisionnement sur le
reste il y a des biens dont on ne
comprend pas la hausse des prix et moi
j'aimerais bien la comprendre alors on
va parler la recette fiscales vous
l'avez abordé tout à l'heure déjà le
gouvernement a dit que le surplus de
recettes fiscale était de 55 milliards
d'euros le projet loi sur le pouvoir
d'achat va coûter 25 milliards ou
qu'elle s'ajoutent déjà 25 milliards qui
ont été distribués depuis le mois
d'octobre du coup est-ce que vous dites
bah tout est financé
déjà moi j'invite le nouveau ministre du
Budget à dire les choses
précisément 55 milliards alors je sais
plus si c'est 25 sur 2021 et 30 sur 2022
au contraire enfin je sais plus quelle
est la séparation entre les deux mais
j'aimerais bien qu'il nous disent qu'il
nous réponde précisément et qui nous
donne les chiffres ça c'est le premier
point le deuxième on a une situation
budgétaire à moins 80 milliards c'est à
dire que notre réussite à fermer il est
de 80 milliards d'euros
donc il y a pas de vrai cagnotte
quand on a un déficit il y a pas de vrai
cagnotte ça c'est clair donc j'aimerais
bien qu'il nous présente une maquette
globale troisième point il nous dit j'ai
des recettes supplémentaires liées à
l'inflation c'est vrai vous prenez la
consommation si vous appliquez 20 % de
TVA sur un prix qui a augmenté ça vous
fait des recettes en plus qui nous
disent aussi combien il a dépensé en
plus parce que l'énergie
ça coûte cher ça vaut pour le carburant
que vous mettez dans les voitures de
police et gendarmerie ça vaut pour le
chauffage que vous pouvez mettre dans le
bâtiment public et ça il nous dit pas
mais si ça veut dire que les mesures
pouvoir d'achat il faut pas les faire
mais on n'a pas les moyens
je vous demande juste qu'il nous disent
un mode de financement global et précis
et c'est pas en disant j'ai plus de
recettes mais nous dit pas s'il a eu
plus de dépenses que il va nous répondre
sur la question du financement cette
question là je la pose depuis avril 2020
donc je peux la reposer à l'infini ce
qui montre que le gouvernement ne nous a
jamais donné de copie sur le financement
qu'il souhaitait mettre en œuvre pour
cette crise et moi je pense comme
certains le soulèvent aujourd'hui qu'il
faudrait une contribution exceptionnelle
notamment des sur les super profits sur
les super profits oui on nettoie
on est face à une crise on est face à 50
vous avez un résultat net rapporté à
votre chiffre d'affaires qui est très
supérieur à la moyenne des autres
entreprises et là vous la moyenne des
années précédentes ou la moyenne des
années précédentes ou vous pouvez
définir un critère qui soit très bien
c'est sans doute au-delà du CAC 40 mais
on peut aussi l'Union européenne nous
autorise enfin la commission pardon à
avoir un ciblage qui peut être que sur
des très grandes entreprises dont on a
vu un refuge c'est total harcelormittal
la CMA et également mais la quatrième
c'est le VMH oui mais on peut le on peut
la alors ça ça passera pas la loi c'est
pour que ça passe la loi faut devenir un
critère précis donc on a 271 très
grandes entreprises qui peuvent dans le
cadre faire voilà qui peuvent être
sujettes à cette grande contribution et
que on définit un critère précis sur le
niveau du résultat net par rapport au
chiffre d'affaires
qu'Elizabeth borne annonce ça mercredi
on verra vous suivrez la spéciale
je vous promets que si elle le met dans
son discours de politique générale
j'applaudirai mercredi merci beaucoup
merci Tom Yves thréer va entrer dans un
instant donc je vous pose cette question
à propos de Damien Abad qui a dit sa
frustration de ne pas pouvoir rester de
gouvernement manifestement Emmanuel
Macron lui a demandé de le quitter il a
dénoncé et la calomnie ignoble devenue
une arme politique
sur la question qui nous intéresse
peut-être c'est effectivement de savoir
quelle doit être la reine dans ses
affaires qui se multiplient avec un
impact sur l'opinion publique qui est
important des principes démocratiques
qui sont fondamentaux comment combine
tout ça aujourd'hui alors c'est
effectivement
le principe de
présomption d'innocence doit être
préservée mais quand vous constituez une
équipe gouvernementale pour la France
vous devez prendre le maximum de
garanties possibles ou le maximum de
précaution ou je sais pas comment il
faut le dire donc que le Président de la
République est demandé à Damien Abad
qui n'est pas solide souhaitait le
renommer au gouvernement je comprends
cette position là est-ce qu'elle est
juste ou pas juste
elle éventuellement juste elle
éventuellement je n'en sais rien mais
quand vous êtes à la président de la
République de la France
effectivement vous devez prendre le
maximum de garanties sur votre équipe
gouvernementale donc oui que la décision
soit juste ou pas juste
on reconnaît que le Président de la
République ben voilà fait preuve de plus
de comment dire
ça dépend que les garanties à 100% mais
non mais ça n'existe pas ça n'existe pas
mais vous en tout cas ce que vous dites
c'est dit qu'il y a l'apparition d'une
c'est ça quand je vous demande quelle
est la règle dès qu'il y a l'apparition
d'une accusation portée en justice on
doit immédiatement
retirer son mandat à
dire pas un président de la commission
des finances on va parler tout à l'heure
mais par exemple un ministre c'est ça la
règle que vous appliqueriez c'est pas
c'est pas une règle
la prise il faut que on puisse
réaffirmer dans notre pays je sais que
c'est très compliqué la présomption
d'innocence sinon ça veut dire que ce
principe là n'existe plus maintenant
vous reformez un gouvernement vous avez
le droit d'avoir un principe je peux
aussi un principe de précaution je sais
pas comment il faut le dire d'ailleurs
mais d'appliquer une forme de précaution
à votre équipe
très hard quand on est un peu un
principe de précaution
bonsoir
du Parti socialiste je vous dis sur ce
que vous avez dit tout à l'heure disons
si j'ai mais madame borne nous propose
de taxer les super profits des
entreprises j'applaudirai et
voilà est-ce que
j'aimerais que savoir pourquoi
finalement qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait pour
que vous rejoignez la majorité quels
sont les deux ou trois thèmes auxquels
vous tenez et qui ferait que vous
pourriez ici ou là votez avec la
majorité
mais déjà si vous regardez sous le
précédent quinquennat il y a plusieurs
textes beaucoup de textes où nous avons
voté y compris une loi de finance
rectificative qui était celle du 25
avril 2020 la première pour lorsqu'on a
commencé à rentrer dans le confinement
donc nous l'avons voté on l'a voté donc
nous ne sommes pas dans une opposition
systématique nous regardons texte par
texte vous me demandez de me positionner
sur le au cours de la Première ministre
dont je n'ai absolument aucune idée des
mesures qu'il va contenir je vous ai dit
quels sont les deux ou trois idées
auxquelles vous tenez que vous attendez
du premier le pouvoir d'achat sur le la
revalorisation salariale quand on
regarde les données de l'OCDE on en a
parlé Miss SMIC à 1500 euros qu'est-ce
qu'elle veut faire sur le financement de
cette crise on va pas pouvoir
éternellement faire comme si le quoi
qu'il en coûte
ça n'existe pas dans le fond c'est parce
qu'il y a toujours quelqu'un qui paye
donc on reboucle sur la question des
supers profits vous venez de mentionner
éventuellement leur établissement de
l'impôt sur la fortune non mais ça je le
réclame depuis 5 ans voilà cinq ans je
peux le continuer à leur réclamer et le
troisième volet c'est qu'elle nous
explique comment notre pays va pouvoir
être en capacité de continuer à créer et
à fabriquer de la valeur on voit bien
que par exemple au premier trimestre
2022 le nombre d'heures travaillées a
baissé par rapport au nombre d'heures
travaillées en 2021 donc on voit bien
qu'on a une petite lame de fond qui est
assez inquiétante on voit bien que le
nombre d'emplois dans l'industrie
continue de baisser et que ce que nous
avons connu par exemple sur les
médicaments et bien il faudrait pas que
ça se retrouve sur d'autres secteurs et
ça elle ne nous a pas donné le début du
mode d'emploi de sur cette question là
à gauche nous avons appelé ça à la
planification écologique vous l'appelez
comme vous voulez mais c'est être en
capacité quand on a un pays de 67
millions d'habitants d'avoir un peu de
pilotage sinon c'est du CAF permanent et
le cafouillage n'a jamais créé de valeur
que vous dénoncez ça fait cinq ans qu'il
existe
ça fait un certain temps qu'il existe
moi le Tarn-et-Garonne qui est mon
département qui est un des plus
ensoleillés de France et bien vous avez
un certain nombre de bâtiments
commerciaux qui s'installent des
bâtiments logistiques il y a pas un
panneau photovoltaïque sur les toits
vous trouvez ça normal si on veut
enclencher la transition écologique
c'est maintenant il faut il faut que ce
soit fait et qu'on fasse en sorte que
les panneaux soient fabriqués en France
de la relocalisation de l'industrie qui
fabrique ici alors sur le plan politique
j'ai compris à travers vos propos vous
n'étiez pas vraiment à l'aise dans cette
nuque là
et que vous êtes jalouse de votre
indépendance est-ce que néanmoins vous
êtes satisfaite de la façon dont le
parti socialiste se comporte aujourd'hui
avec d'abord c'est la première question
alors moi je vais vous parler du
pilotage du groupe socialiste parce que
c'est ce groupe socialiste
par Boris Vallot et j'en suis très
heureuse d'accord vraiment je
nous avons toujours été en capacité nous
avons été ceux qui avaient fait le
référendum d'initiative partagé nous
l'avons écrit qui a empêché la
privatisation des aéroports de Paris
nous avons été ceux qui avons mis la
première proposition de loi pour
inventer l'écocide un concept juridique
qui permet de sanctionner ceux qui
abîment qui abîment la planète de
manière intentionnelle nous avons été
ceux qui avons inventé le minimum
jeunesse nous avons été ceux qui avons
proposé de l'expérimentation de ce qu'on
appelait inversement automatique du
revenu de base nous avons été ceux qui à
m'ont proposés qu'on forme 15.000
médecins par an en France au lieu des 10
000 11000 donc nous avons été ceux qui
avons beaucoup produits en termes
d'idées en termes d'essayer de faire
avancer un certain nombre de concepts
qui permettent de tracer un nouvel
horizon pour la société ce groupe là il
faut qu'il garde cette marque de
fabrique là et gardez cette marque de
fabrique c'est continuer à créer c'est
comme comme fait du vélo si vous me
pédalez plus vous tombez ce groupe là
avec le Parti socialiste
je pense que oui mais en tout cassette
ce cap là moi je peux vous dire que
Boris Vallot a bien l'intention le
garder d'être en capacité de continuer
continuer à mettre des idées sur la
table et apporter aussi nos propres
idées parce que si nous avions que les
idées de la France insoumise nous
serions chez la France insoumise nous
sommes nous-mêmes et être soi-même c'est
avoir un groupe qui est à la fois loyal
et libre alors vous qui appartenez à ce
groupe est-ce que vous êtes en phase
avec l'intention du Parti socialiste de
procéder à une purge c'est-à-dire à
exclure des militants et des
responsables du parti socialiste non tel
qu'il a été non vous êtes en désaccord
avec ce que Olivier Faure qui fait
partie pourtant de votre groupe a décidé
tout seul
parmi les personnes concernées il y a un
ancien président de conseil
départemental de l'Ardèche et d'autres
voilà j'ai vu la liste donc non je suis
en désaccord et vous l'avez dit Olivier
Faure je l'ai dit et comment ça va
terminer tout ça
j'imagine
au sein du parti donc ça concerne pas le
groupe socialiste
mais est-ce que
vous allez rester dans ce parti vous
personnellement mais moi j'y suis depuis
2000 je m'y sens très bien je pense que
ce parti aurait intérêt à retrouver
alors à l'époque ça fait peut-être un
peu old fashion des motions c'est à dire
que ce parti il a réussi à faire
cohabiter la social-démocratie
version Moscovici Dominique Strauss-Kahn
Rocard
beaucoup plus à gauche version emmanuely
bon toutes ces personnalités vous dire
que c'était quand même les personnalité
que voilà et du coffre se laissait pas
imposer ou en tout cas dictée quoi que
ce soit vous voulez et Lionel Jospin et
d'autres ont réussi à faire en sorte que
ce parti soit soit rassemble toutes ces
synthèse ou en tout cas qu'on puisse
avoir un vrai débat d'idée donc moi je
ne suis pas pour la pensée unique je
pense que la pensée unique c'est le
rabougrissement permanent et
bravouissement mais à la fin il reste
plus rien donc pas de penser unique vous
êtes pour le rétablissement des ce qu'on
appelait les sensibilités
d'accord et qu'est-ce qui va se passer
il va y avoir un congrès du Parti
socialiste sans doute à l'automne il va
avoir lieu à l'automne est-ce que vous
êtes pour la reconduction de Monsieur
Olivier Faure à la tête de ce parti
d'abord on verra qui est candidat on
verra ce qu'on propose mais moi j'ai
déjà été signataire j'ai porté une
motion en 2015 qui s'appelait La
Fabrique qui avait un grand objectif
c'était réconcis enfin faire le lien
entre les frondeurs et le pouvoir
ça n'a pas marché mais nous avions quand
même fait un bon score honorable lors de
cette dans ce congrès ce qui d'ailleurs
a fait monter des jeunes aujourd'hui
vous avez Arthur de la porte qui a 30
ans qui siège qui a été élu dans le
Calvados qui faisait partie de cette
motion là fabrique et donc cet automne
vous avez aimé la vie donc tout ceci
sera reposé à l'automne et moi je vais
pas vous de dévoiler quoi que ce soit
parce que pour l'instant rien n'est
décidé dernière question d'Olivier Faure
ou de Carole d'Elga
avec Carole Delga j'ai une histoire
incarnée par l'Occitanie
elle est ma présidente de région elle a
réussi je pense que ce que personne
aurait réussi à faire une fusion de deux
grandes régions Midi-Pyrénées
Languedoc-Roussillon qui ont des
cultures différentes et aujourd'hui
l'Occitanie c'est la seule la seule
région de France dont le montant
l'investissement dépasse les 3% de son
PIB sur les 20 régions européennes qui
investissent le plus sur la recherche il
y a qu'une région française c'est
laquelle c'est l'Occitanie donc cette
cette volonté là sur l'avenir elle est
extrêmement importante et je remercie
vraiment Carole delgane la portée
est-ce que je suis plus proche si vous
voulez que je vous répondre je vous
répondre cash parce que je sais
qu'est-ce que vous attendez oui je suis
plus proche de Carole Delga voilà merci
beaucoup
Elisabeth merci beaucoup est-ce que vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure je vous repose
la question et on va évidemment
maintenant accueillir Richard rameau du
MoDem est-ce que vous pensez possible
que Macron renonce à sa promesse
présidentielle de modifier et de reculer
le départ de l'âge légal à la retraite
pour ce que quel est votre je suis pas
vraiment dans le secret du pouvoir mais
vous vous l'avez observé vous l'avez
combattu vous le connaissez est-ce que
vous pensez que il peut scanner sur ce
sujet si pour prendre votre expression
donc il peut caler
en tout cas vous le souhaitez et vous
guettez encore une fois vous le
souhaitez non mais je souhaite pas pour
le pour le souhaiter c'est pas un vœu
c'est juste de dire j'ai été pendant
tout le mois d'avril pendant le la
campagne présidentielle j'ai pas arrêté
de dire que cette réforme n'était pas
nécessaire et que son seul objectif
c'était de faire rentrer 15 milliards
d'euros dans les caisses de l'État par
an bon il a fallu attendre l'interview
de la première ministre dans une les
colonnes du JDD pour dire effectivement
ça va faire entrer des recettes
supplémentaires je suis très heureuse
qu'elle ait eu l'honnêteté de le dire de
dire cette réforme fait rentrer des
recettes supplémentaires qui peuvent
servir à autre chose moi ce que je dis
juste à la majorité salut mon collègue
c'est que on peut
faire financer autrement parce que faire
récupérer 15 milliards d'euros sur les
retraites c'est faire payer ceux qui ont
l'espérance de vie la plus courte
c'est-à-dire souvent des personnes qui
ont eu des métiers pénibles ceux qui
gagnent le moins et bien moi je suis pas
d'accord avec ça voilà c'est dit alors
je vous le présente mais vous le
connaissez
beaucoup d'être dans ce studio pour
avoir un débat une disputation on va
appeler ça dans cette émission avec
Valérie rabot vous êtes un spécialiste
entre autres bien sûr des questions
alimentaires et peut-être que c'est un
rapport avec le projet de loi pouvoir
d'achat je vous laisse la parole
oui on le voit bien et on le verra à la
rentrée les produits alimentaires on en
parle flambe et donc moi j'ai été
c'était juste avant qu'on passe aux
élections j'avais demandé une commission
d'enquête sur le juste prix c'est quoi
un juste prix et donc effectivement là à
coup sûr il y a des gens qui exagèrent
notamment dans la partie liquide auquel
les gens essaient de faire facturer plus
cher alors qu'ils n'ont pas des surcoûts
de production
ils sont en train si on regarde bien
leurs prix il y a des prix qui sont
exagérément élevés aujourd'hui ils
augmentent alors que finalement leur
coût de production n'augmente pas voilà
et puis et donc le pouvoir d'achat ça va
être très très intéressant sur les sur
les produits alimentaires je dis
attention simplement parce que c'est
cette affaire à vouloir aller chercher
des prix toujours les plus bas c'est le
combat de Monsieur Leclerc c'est pour ça
que c'est lui qui a dit cette affaire là
qu'est-ce qu'on va avoir on va avoir des
produits dont certaines PME françaises
seront obligés de changer les recettes
parce que quand vous allez faire un
produit alimentaire et que le Clair va
vous dire ou d'autres il faut baisser le
prix et bien la PME sera obligée de
changer sa recette ou elle sera obligée
de changer par exemple l'emballage c'est
à dire qu'on aura le même emballage on
aura moins de produits à l'intérieur et
donc on va tromper les plus humbles et
donc je dis très très attention à cette
affaire là vous avez des produits très
connus un Nesquik par exemple vous
prenez Nesquik sur 10 ans et bien vous
avez pas la même taux de cacao dans le
chocolat et donc à vouloir à ce que
Bercy veuillez absolument faire des prix
bas et laisse la grande distribution
dans les box de négociation étrangler
nos PME réétrangler nos paysans pour
avoir des prix bas on aura les plus
pauvres qui eux vont récupérer des
produits qui seront les produits
dangereux et je rappelle pardon
excusez-moi qu'on avait réussi depuis
quatre cinq ans ici à faire en sorte que
les premiers prix dans les supermarchés
chez Leclerc s'appelle ecopus soit
quasiment en déroutes ça marchait pas et
aujourd'hui ça reflète mais ces produits
là c'est des produits auxquels on
trouvera plus de sucre plus de gras plus
Bruxelles et donc plus d'obésité et on
sait très bien que la courbe de
l'obésité suit la courbe de la pauvreté
et suit notamment dans la covid les plus
fragiles ce que vous partagez ce tableau
oui alors non mais il a raison c'est à
dire si les contraintes qui peuvent être
imposées sur les prix peuvent se
traduire par le fait que au lieu de
mettre du beurre vous mettez de l'huile
autre enfin qui peut coûter moins cher
ou etc etc dans la recette donc ça c'est
un vrai sujet mais il le sait aussi
parce que on avait beaucoup
bataillé dans l'hémicin de l'Assemblée
nationale la loi egalim 1 version 1
celle votée en 2018 nous nous avions
proposé qui est véritablement une forme
de juge de paix sur ce qu'elle coûte
production c'est à dire quand vous
fabriquez quand vous élevez du veau par
exemple et bien vous avez besoin soit
d'avoir une prairie et puis ça vous avez
des coups de fioul etc etc enfin on
pouvait mettre un certain nombre de
coups de revient ça a été refusé par la
majorité je le regrette et nous nous
donc ça c'est le premier sujet que nous
avions proposé le deuxième c'était
d'avoir des vrais contrats tripartite
c'est-à-dire qu'on met l'agrand
distribution les transformateurs et les
agriculteurs autour de la table et force
est de constater et là pour le
gouvernement pour le coup le
gouvernement a été transparent
c'est-à-dire que en 2019 2020-2021 le
gouvernement a publié l'état des
négociations entre la grande
distribution et les
agriculteurs 2019 - 0,4%
2020 où tout le monde a redécouvert
l'agriculture 0% sur les tarifs
pratiqués 2021 - 0,3 alors je sais que
les pourcentages ça s'additionnent pas
comme ça on va faire -04 + 0 et - 0,3 ça
fait -07 versez aux agriculteurs ben moi
je suis pas d'accord alors qu'on voit
que donc j'espère que la négociation en
elle va faire deux choses voir s'il y a
pas des spéculations qui sont
enclenchées par certains parce qu'il
doit y en avoir quand même il y a des
produits je ne comprends pas qu'ils
aient autant augmenté et faire en sorte
que les agriculteurs soient payés
les produits pardon que vous visez c'est
quoi en particulier je sais pas quand je
vois que l'huile de tournesol on voit
des bouteilles qui sont passés à 3,80 €
voir plus le litre et qui passait de 1
euro ou 20 ou un euro 50 pour certaines
il y a quand même pour nos agriculteurs
il faut penser aussi qu'il y a beaucoup
de produits de nos PME qui sont
transformés et c'est quand on essore les
PME dans le box de négociation que ça se
répercute sur le paysan qui est
aujourd'hui est mal payé et aujourd'hui
là au moment où on parle dans la grande
distribution jamais les pénalités
logistiques n'ont été aussi importantes
je m'explique aujourd'hui vous allez
vous avez des sur l'emballage le carton
c'est compliqué et donc vous allez quand
même prendre votre marché et vous allez
livrer le supermarché il va vous mettre
jusqu'à 20% en ce moment au moment où on
parle là 20% de pénalité c'est du jamais
vu de en réalité logistique et donc il
faut absolument que les degrés tombent
puisque la loi avait été mais les
décrets ne sont pas encore tombées il
faut arrêter parce que ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que je dis à une PME et
bien finalement je vais essayer de faire
un peu de la ristourne et je vais te
mettre 20 % de pénalités logistique la
PME qu'est-ce qu'elle va faire elle va
le coup d'après réintégrer ces frais
logistiques et donc on va on va que ça
et ça ce qu'ils font c'est aujourd'hui
des gens comme Michel Édouard
c'est quand même un sujet important on a
une structure nous on a quatre grandes
centrales d'achat en France
4 grosses ce qui est pas le cas des
autres pays par exemple en Allemagne il
y en a beaucoup plus et la corollaire de
ça c'est qu'effectivement l'inflation a
beaucoup plus augmenté en Allemagne
qu'en France alors on voit bien que il y
a toujours un juste équilibre à trouver
à la fois pour que l'inflation n'explose
pas pour les consommateurs et que les
agriculteurs puissent alors vous avez
besoin c'est important
de force qui est beaucoup plus inversé
avec leur 6 ou 4 mais quatre gros
centrales d'achat en tout cas dans notre
pays bien évidemment c'est le chèque
alimentaire c'est une bonne chose mais
moi je veux que le chèque alimentaire il
soit fléchés pour des produits sains
c'est-à-dire qu'on soit capable comment
comme un ticket restaurant aujourd'hui
autrefois les pauvres manger des légumes
et les riches manger de la viande
aujourd'hui les riches et les bobos
mangent des légumes et les pauvres
mangent de la viande
du consommateur non parce que quand vous
avez aujourd'hui des gens qui ne sont
pas informés des gens qui n'arrivent pas
il faut il faut les aiguiller donc moi
je suis pour que comme on a le ticket
restaurant que ce chèque alimentaire
soit fléché pour que les plus humbles
ils puissent aller voir des produits qui
sont des produits les plus sains parce
que sinon on aura des produits qui sont
de mauvaise qualité et importer sur le
principe et ensuite sur le fléchage
alors sur le chèque alimentaire nous
nous l'avions demandé pendant la crise
je passe se souvient sur les débats qui
puissent y avoir effectivement alors un
fléchage on peut le faire de différentes
façons je vois que pendant la la période
de du confinement dans la région
Occitanie la région a acheté les surplus
aux agriculteurs de fruits légumes
fromages et viande qui ont pu être
redistribués à des personnes mais via
évidemment en paiement mais un prix tout
à fait très très raisonnable pour que on
puisse avoir accès à une nourriture
locale de qualité et aussi prendre un
goût à cette nourriture
et donc ça ça vous paraît en plus du
chaque alimentaire un petit peu plus
structurant peut-être comme type d'aide
distribué de la nourriture ça ressemble
des surplus vous agriculteurs non mais
c'était pendant la période du
confinement c'était très excité c'était
temporaire ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'on peut aussi regarder sur la base
des expérimentations qui ont été menées
sur les différents territoires et s'en
inspirer et là c'était vraiment des
produits locaux d'Occitanie qui
permettait aussi de faire connaître un
agriculteur qui est peut-être à 15 km de
chez vous vous avez vous avez compris
vous ce que vous voulez faire le
gouvernement finalement
qui va peut-être atterrir je sais pas en
tout cas on le flèche comme un ticket
restaurant sur les bons produits on a
aujourd'hui
quand on achète un produit dans le
supermarché il y a que deux personnes
qui peuvent payer le consommateur ou le
contribuable et bien moi je suis pour
que ça soit le consommateur et qu'il
paye le juste prix alors vous avez
évidemment rencontré pendant cette
campagne des militants des élus PS
socialistes vous en connaissez ça vous
inspirait quoi par rapport à leur
aliment à la nuque c'est assez marrant
parce que moi j'ai du respect notamment
dans les questions agricoles par
Dominique Pottier notamment mais c'est
parce que on travaille sur ces sujets là
ici ensemble en circonscription j'ai le
député jean-Pierre Sueur alors c'est
assez marrant en off ils sont absolument
pas nups vraiment là les UPS c'est pas
leur truc c'est excessif etc mais quand
on voit sur le terrain quand on revient
à on là finalement quand il faut aller
il faut aller chercher des places et
bien finalement on va on va aller moi ce
que j'espère c'est que j'ai respecté
pour la gauche je crois qu'il y a un
esprit de gauche qui existe mais ils ont
pour beaucoup en tout cas ceux que je
connais moi avec qui je m'entends ici et
aussi en circonscription c'est
absolument pas à l'échelle de
l'hébicycle et de l'Assemblée nationale
vous espérez quoi alors que des gens
intelligents comme Madame rabot quand
les textes vont dans l'intérêt qui est
de sa philosophie dans l'intérêt des
Français il le vote sans calcul
politique alors que moi j'ai vu mais moi
j'ai vu là sur le terrain des
déclarations du Parti socialiste chez
moi puisqu'on me pose la question auquel
j'avais le double discours celui qui
disait ah non jamais la nupette etc puis
quand il fallait aller avec la nuit
Pesse parce qu'il y a des places à
prendre on y va quand même
libre hein
Valérie rabot vous répondez mais
d'abord on verra ce qui va se passer
dans l'hémicycle mais on a toujours une
autre ligne de conduite et ça ça va pas
boucher mais jusqu'à présent vous étiez
vous étiez unique j'ai envie de dire là
vous êtes vous êtes remis dans un
ensemble qui est plus grand et j'espère
qu'il vous emmènera pas mais on est il y
a quatre groupes il y a un groupe écolo
il y a un groupe PC il y a un groupe
socialiste et apparenté il y a un groupe
à les filles il y a un truc qui
s'appelle nupestre et qui de temps en
temps a emporter le tout non mais qui
peut non mais qui porte un certain
nombre c'est sur le SMIC à 1500 euros on
est tous d'accord donc autant qu'on
avance ensemble après il y aura d'autres
sujets sur l'hôpital il y a nous avons
aussi notre propre proposition et nos
propositions que nous mettons sur la
table enfin il y a différents sujets sur
lesquels vous inquiétez pas
en tout cas pour ma part je garde aurai
votre libre de liberté voilà si il y a
des propositions qui sont intéressantes
nous les voterons alors à propos de
proposition
j'ai envie de soumettre la question sur
la suppression de la redevance
audiovisuelle est-ce que ça permet c'est
une bonne mesure pour redonner du
pouvoir d'achat alors aux Français ça
c'est l'hypocrisie la plus totale donc
supprimer la redevance audiovisuelle
donc il faut quand même trouver près de
3 milliards d'euros pour financer lieu
du visuel public on dit pas comment on
fait
ça c'est caché derrière on dit pas
comment on fait et en même temps parce
que en même temps revient au 1er janvier
2023 vous allez avoir une hausse décidée
par la majorité sur les ordures
ménagères alors vous à Paris vous serez
pas concerné mais nous qui vivons dans
des communes plus rurales où il y a pas
d'incinérateur ça va faire l'équivalent
pour une famille de deux parents et deux
enfants l'équivalent de 130 à 140 euros
de plus à payer de taxes sur les ordures
ménagères et donc c'est à nouveau ce qui
vivent à la campagne qui vont la payer
alors vous voyez bien d'un côté vous
dites je vais supprimer ça mais je
remets ça de l'autre côté donc ça c'est
une hypocrisie mais bon
elle est liée à la suppression de de
lait absolument pas lié mais comme vous
me posez la question comme redonne du
pouvoir d'achat pour payer cette table
non vous me posez la question du pouvoir
d'achat je vous dis juste qu'il y a une
hypocrisie derrière tout ça et
l'hypocrisie c'est donc ça déjà parce
que il y a une Dax jusqu'à supprimer et
une autre qui est ajoutée mais c'est
déjà voté c'était voté sous le pressé
d'un président quinquennat et ça va
entrer en oeuvre au 1er janvier 2023 et
la deuxième hypocrisie c'est que vous ne
dites pas où vous trouvez enfin pas vous
mais le gouvernement ou la majorité oui
je me sens pas non mais voilà
l'équivalent des 3 milliards d'euros qui
sont nécessaires alors sur les sur les
ordures ménagères je sais pas s'il y a
l'air devant sa citative chez vous je
crois pas et donc moi je pense que
planquer la taxe sur les ordures
ménagères dans l'impôt c'est une
mauvaise chose il faut responsabiliser
les gens moi j'ai fait dans mon
territoire j'en étais à l'initiative une
redevance qui fait qu'en fonction de la
production de mes déchets et bien là je
vais pouvoir payer sur la redevance
incitative et tant qu'on n'aura pas mis
devant sa citative en France je pense
que c'est normal de faire une taxe sur
les ménagères parce que il y a comme ça
finalement honnêtement qu'on arrive à
faire baisser moi j'ai fait baisser en
trois ans de 32% de volume des déchets
par an ça c'est la première des choses
sur l'audiovisuel public moi je le dis
très clairement je serai dans la un
grand défenseur de l'université quitte à
être contre le gouvernement je pense que
la madame rabot a raison moi je pense
que c'était bien de supprimer cette taxe
mais par contre il faut dire on la prend
pour moi il faut la prendre sur les
Google sur le numérique sur des gens qui
qui qui le fait mais il faut un autre
duel pick fort et je serai la culture
précisément on a besoin nous dans nos
circonscriptions d'avoir également un
France 3 France Bleu qui soit sur le
territoire et je dirais même financement
par une taxe effectivement sur tous ces
nouveaux usages alors la taxe sur les
nouveaux usages qui a fait voter à
l'Assemblée nationale en 2016 la taxe
dit Youtube c'est moi c'est un
amendement
a beaucoup travaillé aussi je l'ai fait
de voter 12 voix à 11 j'ai gagné d'une
voix le vote c'était dans une nuit à
vendredi donc ce que je veux dire c'est
que j'ai pas de problème là-dessus c'est
de dire sur les nouveaux usages aussi
sur le parce qu'effectivement
l'audiovisuel les dieux visuels évoluent
mais ce que je voudrais ce que je trouve
irresponsable de la part du gouvernement
c'est dire je supprime la redevance télé
j'enlève 3 milliards d'euros ou à peu
près pas tout à fait de recettes à
l'audiovisuel public et je ne dis pas
comment je le finance c'est
irresponsable donc c'est plutôt le
principe même de supprimer une taxe à un
moment de en pleine campagne électorale
sans dire comment ces financé qui vous
choquent et pas la suppression en tant
que tel vous parce que d'autres disent
la supprimer c'est déjà mettre en
fragilité l'indépendance de chaque fois
mettre en pratique parce que si on
reprend l'histoire la suppression de la
publicité sur une partie des plages
horaires de l'audiovisuel public les
promesses du l'ancien président de la
République Nicolas Sarkozy n'ont pas été
mise en oeuvre n'ont pas été tenues les
résultats des courses depuis 2017
l'audiovisuel public a perdu 190
millions d'euros 190 millions d'euros
presque 200 millions d'euros de recettes
donc on ne peut pas demander à
l'audiovisuel public d'assurer
véritablement une information de qualité
d'avoir ce poids là pour notre société
et en même temps lui supprimer 180
heures il faudrait on va maintenant
rejoindre Vincent roux partant en
partant des règles du Figaro live
Vincent vous êtes avec nous oui
vous êtes avec nous et voilà Vincent une
question pour finir à Valérie Rabault
oui une question toute simple est-ce que
vous voterez le projet de loi veille et
sécurité sanitaire qui doit être
présenté à la fin du mois en
remplacement de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire je ne sais pas ce qu'il y a
dedans je ne fais pas de chèques en
blanc donc je verrai quand j'aurai pris
connaissance du texte et surtout des
amendements que nous aurons pu
éventuellement y apporter alors question
est-ce que vous êtes favorable à un
amendement ou vous déposeriez un
amendement qui permettrait la ré des
personnels de santé non vaccinés alors
je moi je suis pas médecin j'aimerais
que là j'entends dire que l'épidémie
repart en tout cas le nombre de cas
repart donc j'aimerais qu'on ait un état
précis de la situation sanitaire qu'on
puisse aussi avoir des éclairages de
médecins donc à ce stade
ben écoutez je
j'attends de j'attends non mais ça
marche mais vous pouvez dire que je
botte en touche c'est vrai j'espère que
d'ici fin juillet non mais j'espère que
d'ici fin juillet au moment où on aura
le vote du texte on pourra avoir ses
réponses là parce que honnêtement
effectivement il y a un certain nombre
de personnels qui ont dû quitter enfin
qui ont dû quitter leur emploi parce
qu'ils ne souhaitait pas se faire
vacciner on a quand même vu que le
vaccin avait empêché les formes graves
voilà donc ça ce point là je souhaite
qu'on puisse avoir tous les éclairages
possibles
d'ici le 20 juillet ou je sais pas quand
tu es ce sera voté le 20 le 22 alors
l'hypothèse c'est que dans changer le
loyer de mesure le droit de collecter
les données également de contrôler les
frontières pour évidemment prévenir la
propagation de l'épidémie n'est plus
question de pas se vaccinale est-ce que
c'est une bonne chose non mais les
frontières c'est très bien ça je pense
que c'est important sur la collecte de
données alors là on avait eu des grands
grands grands débats parce que
on voit bien que sur un certain nombre
on avait fait moi j'avais déposé alors
je sais plus exactement quels étaient
les termes un recours aux conseils
constitutionnel sur la protection des
données notamment les données médicales
et le Conseil constitutionnel nous a
donné raison on nous avait donné raison
c'était sur le premier texte du 11 mai
2020 donc ça date il y a quand même déjà
un peu plus de deux ans donc protection
des données on doit être très vigilant
parce que j'ai pas envie que les données
sanitaires médicales etc tombent chez
des gars femme américain que ce soit
utilisé aussi par des grandes sociétés
pour différentes je sais pas pour
fabriquer des médicaments ou autre et
que on est aucun contrôle là-dessus et
le passe d'un mot le passe vaccinal
c'est une bonne chose de ne pas le
remettre dans le texte le recours au
Passe vaccinal je pense qu'il vaut mieux
ne pas le remettre dans le texte voilà
c'est dit c'est clair merci à vous
Valérie Rimbaud d'avoir participé et
l'invité de cette édition publique merci
beaucoup Richard rameau d'avoir mis le
doigt aussi sur des questions très
concrètes on se retrouve ce sera la
dernière de la saison dans une semaine
dans auditions publiques sur Public
Sénat et la Chaîne Parlementaire elle
s'est fait bonne soirée
[Musique]